moscou continue à vivre sa vie post
confinement théâtres et musées bars et
restaurants salles de sport et salons de
beauté tout est ouvert
le maire de moscou sergueï sobianine
envisage même à la levée des dernières
restrictions sanitaires on additionne à
2 j'espère que nous avons surmonté le
pire
même si quelque chose arrive de nouveau
nous avons évolué et nous savons comment
traiter comment lutter contre cette
maladie est ce qu'il faut faire
dieu nous en garde en cas de nouvelles
situations à caractère épidémiologique
ou d'autres défis et aux auront évolué
sur prêts à y faire face
beaucoup mieux qu'il ya un an c'est
également un grand avantage je
n'approuve pas vraiment la levée des
restrictions
parce que au moins comme ça je veux
porter ce bandana steely au lieu d'un
masque
je suis très content de l'ambiance qui
s'installe à moscou beaucoup de
personnes ne prêtent aucune attention
aux coffee beaucoup sont fatigués de
devoir porter les masques et d'observer
la distanciation sociale surtout que
dans le métro
personne ne la respectent à mes yeux
c'est une bonne chose à faire
le moment est venu
l'essentiel est d'éviter la troisième
vague si tout va bien après la levée des
restrictions alors qu'ils élèvent les
gens sont fatigués du mode de vie que
nous vivons actuellement
j'ai l'impression de vivre comme dans
des cages on veut la liberté sait très
bien qu'en russie bien que nos
frontières soient fermés
nous tenions nous continuons à
travailler commencions à aller aux
concerts en un mot la vie continue et
nous revenons à la vie pas de nouveau
confinement en vue pas de pénurie de
vaccins la russie en enregistré 3 moscou
où les terres en paradis sur terre on
de l'hérault confiné au mit le froid
décourageant